[Music]
a utah man has been arrested on
accusations he started a wildfire while
trying to burn a spider with his lighter
oh yeah
with the spider outside of his log cabin
that was connected to a row of hay that
went to the forest i wish i wish it was
that link that sounds like some [ __ ] a
kid would [ __ ] do huh i wonder if he
lit the spider on fire and it was one of
those furry [ __ ] and so it was
like a match and the spider ran away
into a ball of hay yeah oh
like arachnophobia oh [ __ ]
i'm assuming he fully missed the spider
maybe like burned his own fingers like
ow threw the [ __ ] lighter away and
just burned some other guys get carried
away i think you're carried away with
that power as usual we don't know what
happened to the spider oh [ __ ] sorry
i'll tell you that right now it's all
good
we have no clue we have no clue what
happened to spiders so the spider's not
alive we don't know we don't know
um
but he was hiking on monday on whatever
they say monday
this school is burning a spider on a
hike it's not even in your house the
[ __ ] is wrong with you hiking in the
foothills south of salt lake city near
spring the springville which is a city
over there
and and uh he acknowledges taking out
his lighter and starting the fire but
didn't explain why he was trying to burn
the spider he just saw it they didn't
pepper spray this fool that just sounds
like some guy [ __ ] yeah or it's like i
wonder why he admitted that exactly or
it sounds like a cover-up yeah exactly
he was trying to start a forest fire and
then he had successful it sounds like a
freestyle story like you couldn't think
of what to say i was trying to burn uh
a spider he doesn't want his parents to
know that he was smoking a joint oh he's
a little pothead
he's 26 years old yeah don't you guys
feel like in in the current uh
for lack of a better term climate of the
world
starting a forest fire isn't that like
one of the worst crimes that could
possibly happen
like that yeah
plus like global warming and like our
ecosystem just getting [ __ ] if you
start a forest fire that's like almost
worse than murder well this is this is
in utah though bro this isn't this ain't
gonna be a forest fire they got a lot of
trees too but you know what it's a
wildfire
you said they're only six years old no
he's 26. oh 26. i was like six he's six
he was hiking alone almost six years old
this one needs a death penalty he's a
scrappy little fella he's true
and this is just an average guy he's not
like a [ __ ] crazy crackheader so he
was found with a jar of marijuana in his
belongings that's it told you dude told
you it was a [ __ ] pothead but he
didn't appear to be high said the
sheriff who who uh arrested who joined
him in smoking
because he sobered up when he saw the
fires what happened i just want to see
how like a wildfire started i just want
to watch this scenario of like because a
lot of times in la you hear about like a
homeless guy or a homeless encampment
started a fire and he left it i just
want to see how that spreads into
the [ __ ] there's a malibu there's a
fire next to jill's mom's house
literally every like three to six months
so i'll just hang out over there and
i'll just observe yeah and it's because
so there's like a homeless encampment
like
pretty much like like you see that
purple wall yeah like if this was gio's
mom's house there's like a homeless
enchantment there and there's like three
or four of them and then behind them
it's like this empty warehouse
and sometimes you'll just see like a
slow like embers
i don't know if they're trying to keep
warm or whatever sometimes it's like a
faulty electrical outlet and uh and
sometimes they'll get really big and
then the the firefighters come and then
they're they're annoyed too because
they're like [ __ ] they know how it
starts yeah like [ __ ] outta [ __ ] put
this [ __ ] out because that guy right
there no one will take care of him or
yeah you know there's a fire like every
day in downtown downtown l.a i put i've
had to run out with my own extinguisher
and put the alley out
because because like some guy just
really no reason at all just saw a pile
of trash and just wanted to burn it
just [ __ ] random sky stuff dude and
that's when i realized that one of those
tanks of like the fire extinguishers
there's barely anything in that [ __ ] oh
you didn't walk through all of them i
had i went through the whole [ __ ]
tank
and that [ __ ] wasn't even close to being
out
there's not that much you that's why
when they tell you when you have to
stock fire extinguishers they get the
biggest one they really mean that [ __ ]
bro the small one ain't gonna do nothing
i had the medium one and that [ __ ] was
gone they can't figure that [ __ ] out yet
was it bigger than this one
no that's that's good there's a good one
i think so okay mine was the one right
below that and i just even that's not
gonna have that much you're not gonna
put out a real [ __ ] fire with that
really nah i thought that thing still
works probably [ __ ] older than i am
you you'd have to i mean that's good for
like
if you're is this an expiration date
yeah it probably is it says 2016 oh [ __ ]
oh we're still good if you're getting a
fire that's just started but if it's
already burning you're not [ __ ] doing
that well if that's expired do you think
can we sit on like the rolly chairs
outside and still see if we can shoot
like go anywhere can we please do that
actually yeah that'd be tight don't just
throw that away we gotta try that but
when that [ __ ] when you breathe it in it
[ __ ] oh yeah it just sucks but will we
will we no propelled probably stupid guy
[ __ ] i got a buddy who had pepper spray
i mean guys are [ __ ] we're so stupid
i got a buddy who had pepper spread and
then he like he like thought it would be
funny if he shot it at his own leg so he
shoots his own leg with it and i'm
standing like as close as anthony is to
me right now and he shoots in love with
it and i immediately like get to win
it's gonna get you yeah he'll get you he
did it indoors no we were outside okay
but he still shot his own leg with it
out of nowhere he's just like look i'm
like what is that he's like it's pepper
spray so you check it out what did he
think it's gonna be a laser and just
stay in that spot i don't [ __ ] know
but why did you do that to your own leg
so then he's like ah [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] and
then i'm like coughing my ass off i had
no idea who's even gonna do that that's
why because it's kind of funny it is
pretty [ __ ] funny it's like jackass
do you miss doing guy [ __ ]
because i feel like we do still do it
but then we don't like
we don't do it as crazy
i don't even jump in my pool if i think
it's i'm going to get in there and
shiver you know what i mean i like
getting there slowly now like when
you're older you just don't you just
don't want to [ __ ] suffer at all yeah
i never stopped doing guys [ __ ] dude
either i want to burn myself i think i
still do it because remember we were we
were golfing back here and then bart
almost cracked the [ __ ] neighbor's
window i was like you know what i
[ __ ] miss doing [ __ ] like this yeah
and the first thing he says is man but
it feels so good to hit the real ball
right the ping pong ball doesn't do it
it's like i get it doesn't get your
rocks off nah nah dude the last time i
did some real guys [ __ ] is i collected
all the trimmings of my palm tree and
then i sweeped up all of the debris and
then i put it in a bonfire and i made
the world's largest [ __ ] fire that i
could ever possibly make oh that's tight
where was this but it was like a
responsible
guy [ __ ] yeah you know what's a good
reason to have to do guy [ __ ] once you
have a kid why like taika had this
little dinosaur that he said died so he
wanted to like dig a hole in the
backyard and bury it and then of course
mom's not there so he was like trying to
dig and i was like
do you want a shovel and he goes you
just see his eyes light up like oh [ __ ]
we're going to use grown-up stuff for
kid stuff and i dug him like the biggest
[ __ ] hole ever and he was so [ __ ]
happy just to do like take whatever he's
doing but add like adult energy into it
yeah and he buried a toy yeah did he
leave it there
or was he like i need to bring him back
a little no he was dead because mom
killed his dinosaur oh
at least he's sticking to it at least he
knows the dinosaur's blowing the [ __ ]
ground
i agree with that 100
are you gonna like elevate it you're
gonna like you know secretly re-dig it
back up put like bones there and stuff
like that let's put oil dude oh that's
dope yeah put a [ __ ] put it put a gas
a gas can this is fossil fuel son and
then build one of those mini pumps i
just [ __ ] take this start fracking in
your backyard yeah dude
you should start doing that man
get a hoes start blasting that [ __ ]
that's what they do is they blast shale
with water right teach him not to rely
on foreign [ __ ] oil yeah yeah you
need a house only
a that's a teaching moment right there
that is opportunity when i was a kid i
used to just go on my dad's shed and
like dig a hole and then just find stuff
that i think would burn and then i would
go into like his shed because he had a
bunch of chemicals in there and i'd be
like okay what's flammable
and i'll grab this i'm like oh that's
good i like paints whatever and i would
just spray things set it on fire and
just make a little fire pit i was
probably like 11. why did a sound
engineer have so many chemicals uh
breaking bad he uh also does meth
nice
you might not have a drug problem
but
thank you my favorite way to start fires
was [ __ ] magnifying glasses oh that's
the best two right i never got to do it
dude so [ __ ] fun
and then i get a piece of paper and i
get like black crayon or like a black
pen and just [ __ ] make it really
really really dark and that burns it
quicker oh nice dude let's get some
magnifying glasses for the office
let's get the biggest one we could find
let's get our names engraved and then
we'll have our own because you know you
could do it the paper will smoke but it
burns way quicker when you make it black
dude think about how much we'll take our
walks the next level if we're setting
[ __ ] on fire no i'm gonna i'm gonna
check what's on amazon all the vitamin d
we're gonna get somebody's sick man i'm
down burn everything how long do you
think we can point the magnifying glass
at our arm before it starts yeah before
somebody's a [ __ ] and says no no no no
yeah that's the good second second i've
done that before seconds yeah like when
you have it like really focused if you
go like this it's like [ __ ] seconds
yeah it burns i accidentally i remember
the boy scouts i was doing that and then
i i didn't realize i was holding it and
burned a hole in my pants
boy pants are expensive you got to go to
the store they got a monopoly on that
[ __ ] those green ones huh the green
cargo pants yeah man [ __ ] gun control we
need to control them shits extra
magnifying semi automatic magnifying
glass yeah semi automatic you just buy
it like that i heard that's how they
used to [ __ ] attack other ships back
in the day yeah where they just [ __ ]
magnifying that [ __ ] and they just point
it at that ship and start burning it
that's so dope they just point out the
ocean get all sea for all the seafood
and stuff
just cook the sea boiled seafood comes
to the top
calamari i mean if they'll shock the
fish why not burn them and you just
start eating it with this
[Music]
you